in August of 1962 during amazing fantasy
number 15 Marvel will introduce a
character who will become someone the
teenagers can identify with in addition
to changing the archetype of teenagers
in the comic book universe he will
become one of the most popular
superheroes of all time and rise to the
position of Marvel's flagship character
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today we're going to be talking about
spider-man
so one of the most common questions that
I hear with regards to spider-man is why
was he so popular because spider-man
sucks and just in terms of his powers he
is not that strong of a character and in
truth you're right I mean if you're one
of these guys who argues that spider-man
is very weak compared to most everybody
else in the Marvel Universe you're 100%
right I mean you've got the Incredible
Hulk whose physical strength is
virtually limitless there's no end how
strong he can get
you've got the century his molecules
move in instant ahead of the current
time stream and he has virtually every
superhuman power ever and then you got
spider-man who can climb up walls and
shoot wedding out of his wrist I mean
he's just not that strong you're 100%
right but the one thing to bear in mind
is that just because a character is
strong does not mean they're going to be
popular for example if I asked you who's
Polaris a large number of people who may
watch this video in the future won't
know who Polaris's there's no reason for
them to Polaris has never been
introduced to the to the Marvel
multimedia universe I mean with the
exception of season five I think of
x-men in the animated series I mean
she's never been in a movie she's never
even been discussed in a movie and so a
lot of people just don't know who she is
Polaris was a character who had
basically the exact same powers as
Magneto she can manipulate the entire
electromagnetic spectrum albeit maybe
not necessarily as powerful as Magneto
but she was still a formidable person
and she's much stronger than spider-man
was so when it comes to the popularity
of characters it's not just about their
powers it's about the legacy that they
create for themselves and that they
create for the comic-book industry as a
whole with spider-man he came along at a
time when teenagers were largely
considered to either be sidekicks or
they just were bystanders in the Marvel
Universe
they were never a main show they were
never on the main stage
take for example DC Comics the most
popular superhero duo of all time
sidekick and main star was Batman and
Robin everybody knows who Batman and
Robin is there's probably not a soul on
the planet who doesn't know who they are
I could wall
into a hole in Arizona somewhere stick
my head in there and ask people have you
ever heard of Batman and Robin and
chances are they'll say yes they'll know
exactly who they are because they were
so popular but Robin again was a
sidekick and even if you go back and
watch the old Adam West Batman TV show
Robin was a walking joke I mean nobody
ever took him seriously he'd throw out
these stupid little one-liners you know
holy no hair Batman stuff like that like
no one ever took Robin seriously
spider-man was a teenager who just came
onto the scene and was the main show he
was the main star the the main part of
the attraction and teenagers immediately
bonded to that and there were a couple
of reasons why one being a teenager in
general you feel like nobody ever takes
you seriously that's just kind of the
way it is with being a teenager and the
reason for that is because as a teenager
you just don't know everything I mean
there are adults who don't know
everything but there are more adults who
know more than you do but the fact
remains that teenagers just didn't
believe that anyone took them seriously
at the same time they could look at
Peter Parker before he was bit by a
radioactive spider and Peter Parker was
then Peter Parker was the kid who was
being beat up in school he was the guy
who could never get the girl he was the
nerd the one that no one ever took
seriously and then suddenly Peter
Parker's bit by radioactive spider and
he is BAM he's awesome he's getting the
girls flash Thompson's not bullying him
anymore you know he's the cool kid and
so a lot of teenagers could really kind
of dive into the world of spider-man
they could be completely absorbed by the
world of spider-man because it was their
escape from the life in which they lived
and I think it was more so a spider-man
than it was with adult superheroes with
you know even adult superheroes like
Captain America who had sidekicks Bucky
Barnes the Winter Soldier you know Nick
Fury and dum-dum
Oh what was his name dum-dum Dugan I
think was his name he was uh he was a
pretty formidable guy but nonetheless
you know you had these these adults who
were really powerful but teenagers
usually can't identify with adults at
the same time you also got to keep in
mind that spider-man was not fighting
pushovers in his prime during his time
and when he was really kind of at the
peak in the Marvel Universe he wasn't
fighting weak
he wasn't just slinging around with his
webs beating up bank robbers and muggers
and stuff like that I mean he was
fighting big-time villains for example
carnage probably the most formidable
villain that bad I'm sorry that that
spider-man has ever fought the carnage
was the result of the Venom symbiote
having an offspring and of course
because the Venom symbiote had taken
some of the the powers of spider-man
when venom and spider-man were a single
character when it gave birth so to speak
to the carnage symbiote the carnage
symbiote had some of spider-man's powers
so when the carnage symbiote bonded with
Eddie Brock I'm sorry with Cletus Kasady
you had this psychopathic killer who had
bonded to a symbian which in turn
granted him already powerful abilities
who in turn also had some of the powers
of spider-man and so carnage was
extremely durable he was extremely
powerful he was able to go toe-to-toe
with both spider-man and venom at the
same time and overpower them both it
took quite a while for both spider-man
and venom to finally take over or to
defeat a carnage and they actually ended
up defeating him by using some sort of
sound resonance device or something
along those lines but nonetheless the
carnage was a very formidable opponent I
would go as far as to say the carnage
against quite a few opponents and the
Marvel Universe would probably come out
on top in addition spider-man was one of
the Avengers I mean the Avengers don't
induct people for the sake of posterity
they don't induct people just because
they're they're interesting or because
they're fascinating or because they
might help the group look good they
induct them in there because they're one
of the mightiest heroes and that I think
is one of the single greatest aspects of
Peter Parker Peter Parker never gives up
it doesn't matter how bad it gets it
doesn't matter how many people are
falling to the white side and are
absolutely getting demolished Peter
Parker will throw that webbing into a
wall and go slinging in there with
everybody else and that's one of the
reasons why he's such a cool guy the
same time he also has a pretty
formidable intellect he's extremely
smart
especially only being a teenager and so
there are a lot of people who who I
guess kind of grouped together with
Peter Parker in order to figure out
major issues for example Reed Richards
and Peter Parker get together on
occasion with regards to issues on
genetics and various forms of science
beast and Peter Parker team up to engage
in different
and tasks to try to figure out some some
kind of a problem or to develop some
sort of new device or something along
those lines I mean it's not uncommon to
see Peter Parker group in with other
superhero teams in order to achieve a
particular goal so just bear in mind
when it comes to superheroes and their
popularity it's not just based on their
physical power it's also based on the
legacy that they create and what it is
that they've contributed to the Marvel
Universe so with that being said I'm
going to bring this video to an end and
I will catch you guys later peace